Misao lokove filozofije ukratko
izraženo sastoji se u ovome.
Da se opšta predstava,
da se ono što je istinito,
to jest,
da se saznanje zasniva na iskustvu.
Propisuje se kao put saznanja s jedne
strane iskustvo i posmatranje,
a s druge strane analiziranje
i isticanje opštih odredava.
To je empirizam koji metafizicira
i to predstavlja uobičajeni put u naukama.
Ovim Hegelovim rečima
o Lokovoj filozofiji,
koji je napisao u svojoj istoriji
filozofije, započinjemo današnju emisiju.
Poštovani slušalci, u današnjoj emisiji
razgovaramo sa Mašanom Bogdanovskim,
docentom na Filozofskom
fakultetu u Beogradu.
Dobrodošli na gozbu.
Hvala.
Razgovaramo o filozofiji Johna Locke,
o njegove epistemologiji,
ali i o epistemologiji religije.
Ali recite nam pre svega toga,
zašto je uopšte John Locke
značajan za istoriju filozofije,
odnosno kako biste vi odredili taj značaj?
Svakako da najveći značaj leži u tome
da je Locke začetnik modernog empirizma,
empirizma onako kakvog ga nalazimo
u britanskoj školi, a tog filozofska.